okay we are starting to pay closer
attention to 2020 polling for the
Democratic presidential primary I know
that it's still many months I guess
eleven months until we get to the first
Democratic primaries but it is starting
to get more interesting to look at
polling and I mentioned to you last week
that Bernie Sanders is the front-runner
if we look only at candidates who are
actually candidates in other words if we
leave out people who have not yet
declared candidacies like Joe Biden and
look only at those who have said I'm
running Bernie Sanders is the
front-runner he is leading in basically
every poll among those who have formally
declared that they are running but and I
mentioned this last week in most polls
Bernie Sanders is behind Joe Biden Joe
Biden hasn't actually announced that
he's running for president although I
think yesterday on some late-night show
he said I might need your enthusiasm in
a few weeks maybe foreshadowing that he
is indeed going to be running but Joe
Biden despite not even being an official
candidate is still leading in basically
every poll out there so the news is that
there's some good news for Bernie
Sanders on this front Bernie Sanders has
closed the gap with Joe Biden quite a
bit in Iowa which is an important early
primary state we have a new Des Moines
Register CNN Mediacom Iowa poll of
likely Democratic primary voters you
will see that compared to the December
poll Joe Biden has dropped from 32 to
27% support whereas Bernie Sanders has
gained from 19 percent to 25 percent
support so what was a 13-point deficit
for Bernie Sanders to Joe Biden three
months ago is now only a two point
deficit importantly the margin of error
in this poll is four point nine percent
which tells us that Bernie may even be
ahead at this point in time so we don't
know what will happen if Joe Biden
decides to run there's kind of two ways
to interpret these results Pat one is
Bernie announced any's
gaining ground on Joe Biden so things
are looking good for Bernie Sanders the
other interpretation is well Bernie is
gaining but Biden hasn't even announced
and he's still in the lead if Biden
announces we would anticipate he would
surge in the same way that Bernie
Sanders has surged since making his
Kansas candidacy official I genuinely
don't know which is going to happen
yeah me neither and since we're a year
away from the first primaries and
caucuses it's hard to predict I would
imagine that if Biden does decide to run
and he announces he'll have a slight
uptick but I also think that over time
he'll kind of fizzle out he's run for
president twice before and wasn't able
to gain that much traction
I think people support the idea of a
Biden run because they feel nostalgic
for the Obama days and they want to go
back to those days I wonder if that will
persevere or if eventually Biden will
kind of trail off other candidates like
Sanders take the lead I'd like to see
that yeah I'm not sure I mean I agree
with so I agree with your analysis that
I think if Biden enters the race he
immediately sees an uptick I think
without getting into the specifics of
nostalgia for the Obama administration
we're 11 months until the primary in
Iowa history tells us that the
frontrunners today are rarely the
frontrunners when it's actually time to
vote now I know that this is a very
different political environment what
would Donald Trump in the White House
but if you go back to March of 2007
right same amount of time before the
2008 election Barack Obama was polling
nowhere there was no indication in March
of 2007 that Barack Obama was going to
be the next president of the United
States so I I think it's potentially
completely unpredictable who will
ultimately be the nominee based on March
polling for the year before someone who
is really not doing well but again it's
early is Elizabeth Warren she's polling
at 9% and seems unable to get traction
yeah third place still very early but at
some point Elizabeth Warren needs to
start building support and I'm
increasingly concerned Pat that she is
just unable to really
campaign going I just don't see the lane
that she has if Bernie Sanders decided
that he wasn't going to run I could see
Elizabeth Warren's candidacy being
successful because she would win over
the progressives but with Bernie in the
race and with Tulsi Gabbard in the race
too
I just don't see how she can pull it off
it's gonna be an uphill battle for her
yeah although I mean I'm not sure about
the gap isn't gabbard polling like one
percent another pressive candidate in
the mix you know yeah I questioned her
actual progressive credentials as I've
done before but so far it doesn't even
seem like she's going to be a factor
also Kamala Harris interestingly even
though we got a bunch of phone calls and
and a lot of people in the audience seem
to think that the DNC has sort of a
Chosen Kamala Harris in some way shape
or form she also does not seem to be
making any progress whatsoever in
polling but it's very early and who
knows really ultimately what's going to
happen make sure you're following the
David Pakman show on Instagram new
feature on the David Pakman show
Instagram it's called rejected
voicemails we get hundreds of voicemails
on the show and we air four per week we
have a segment called the rejected
voicemails where segments rather
voicemails that didn't make it onto the
show we put on the david pakman show
instagram account at david pakman show
and you can hear some of the wackiness
that doesn't make it onto the show
follow us there we will take a quick
break
psychiatrist dr. John Gartner joins me
next for an update on what he believes
is cognitive decline serious cognitive
decline observable in the President of
the United States that's coming up after
the break one of today's sponsors is
privacy calm slash Pakman this is a free
service that I've actually been using
myself for a while now and I love it you
just take a few seconds to link your
debit card or bank account to privacy
calms mobile app or browser extension
for Firefox and Chrome and what that
does is allow you to instantly create
virtual credit cards that are linked to
your bank account so that you're not
actually putting you
your real debit card number on the
Internet and you use these virtual
credit card numbers to buy things online
and with one click of a button you have
the ability to create multiple virtual
cards delete cards freeze and unfreeze
cards you can put a limit on a card so a
company won't be able to charge you more
than you actually want them to and it
protects you from being hacked it
protects you from companies being hacked
which we've been talking about for a
while on the program and it's perfect
for signing up for free trial somewhere
if you don't want your real credit card
number to be exposed and on file and
their app and browser extension let you
autofill the virtual credit card number
into the credit card field when you're
buying things online there are a ton of
different advantages to shopping and
paying bills with a system like this
everything is totally secure and
encrypted and in some situations you can
earn 5% cash back on your purchases it's
all completely free all you have to do
is click the link under this video to
get started and for a limited time
everybody in our audience who signs up
gets $5.00 towards your first purchase
when you sign up using that link below